Jocelyn how does imagination cultivate
the life of our dreams well to have a
dream to have a life of your dreams you
have to dream and dreaming is
Imagination
you use your imagination to dream you
you use your imagination you know um
Einstein talks about imagination I can't
give you a bunch of clever ones but you
should look them up because Einstein and
Imagination unbelievable another person
that I admire and adore and and was
lucky enough to spend time with as a
child this bookminster Fuller
Buckminster Fuller talks about
imagination look at Buckminster Fuller's
imagination he went against all great
Bucky Fuller designed the geodesic dome
nobody had seen a shape like this this
was an architecture that didn't exist
before but he dared to Dream It's really
that thing of dare to dream when you
dare to dream you engage your
imagination your imagination is the most
powerful thing you have one of the
greatest
problems with young people today is that
they're not reading reading is
singularly the greatest exercise for
your imagination if you and I read the
same book we make two completely
different movies in our heads you have
to visualize the movie you have to
imagine the movie from the book to your
head to your imagination to create a
movie you create one I create another
when we watch a movie we are delivered
the pictures and so we pretty much see
the same movie
when you read you know you have to make
pictures in your head
and this is the problem with with uh
today illiteracy today is all the
pictures are being delivered and they're
being delivered on television they're
being delivered on your computer they're
being delivered on your cell phone
they're just all these and advertising
it's just all pictures delivered so we
get lazy and we don't think we have to
make any pictures in our head well if we
can't make pictures in our head if we
can't if we don't read in order to
engage our imagination if we can't have
a dream because our imagination is
flaccid meaning it has not been
exercised
we we become slaves
we become you know pushed around by
anything that comes in our Viewpoint we
can be led by others with ill intentions
I'm gonna go out on a limb a little bit
now and tell you you know I think when
we look back on this time in history
we'll look at it as corporate terrorism
because it is really this kind of
Corporation the selling of everything
under the sun
um that is stripping away imagination
you strip away imagination you strip
away possibility you strip away
intelligence you strip away greatness
imagination and greatness same thing
nothing great ever happened on the
planet without first being imagined
there is nothing great about selling
Nikes there is nothing great about
buying every small mom and pop
organization just gobbling up that small
business so you can have oh did you have
another quarter that I haven't gotten
from you let me reach in there and get
that quarter two you know it's just it's
it's astounding and it's it's you know
if we don't do something about it it's
going to take take a take down the
take down the human race the planet will
be fine because she doesn't care about
time you know if it takes her another
200 000 years to grow those old
beautiful trees again
she knows what she's doing Bucky Fuller
said you know we should listen to Nature
because she knows exactly what she's
doing and if we just studied a scientist
nature and we took that and rolled the
same principles into our own
sustainability in life we would have no
problems we would have no problems you
know Bucky he was a mathematician he was
he was genius he was the Einstein of our
time but people don't know him as well
Bucky Fuller designed he could put the
entire planet on the island of Haiti in
geodesic domes and have every man woman
and child a millionaire he'd proved
these things mathematically it didn't
make him very popular
with uh with corporate world but you
know he he did that he designed two or
three cars but you know they never they
were wonderful cars but now these people
were making money on cars we're not
going to let you in that that playing
field you know I saw him at the U.N he
you know there's a map they finally got
the map of the world correct a flat map
because they couldn't do a map of the
world flat without it getting warped and
this way or that way so of course Bucky
Fuller came along and said oh I had to
do it and so he did it it's a flat map
and you kind of see it it goes like that
it
it goes in waves kind of like that and
so to introduce this map they drew the
map on the floor of the UN right a giant
version of this map with all the
countries and everything and then they
hired actors and then Bucky did it
mathematically so that you know this you
know in relation to that so the United
States had you know lots of people and
and Africa but you could barely stay in
the space in Africa because there were
too many people and then some countries
only had two people and then he did the
resources
and he did kind of coins and he did that
mathematically and of course the United
States was rolling piles rolling and
rolling in money and then there were
countries that had like one chip this is
this is our resource
and then you know being actors they
started to improvise and so guys from
the United States are like throwing
money into other countries and stuff but
anyway this is all imagination you know
this all comes from his imagination he
had one of the great imaginations of our
time imagination is greatness
do you think most artists actors writers
what have you come from a family
situation where creativity and
Imagination were encouraged or
discouraged and it was an act of
rebellion
you have your head in the clouds all the
time get your head out of that book
you know I'm sure both of those things
are true
I like to think of it as artists come in
with a purpose
then they just forget it so they have to
be reminded but I think both of those
things are true some of them say you
know I'm going to be an artist and some
of them say oh yeah art I should do art
but I think it's a knowingness I think a
lot of times they come in
knowing you know
I I'm different and very often you hear
this thing that I had as a child I feel
different I don't belong I can't quite
fit in these people don't seem authentic
to me they're not behaving honestly but
I don't really understand that you know
they they feel a little betwixt in
between and so it is the struggle to
alleviate that that begins to stimulate
you know the imagination you know I
would go into the garden one of the
greatest gifts my mother gave me was her
Gardens I mean she'd give them to me but
she was an unbelievable Gardener and she
would have these Gardens that some of
the flowers she'd walk by and they were
eye high they were like hello and you
would so you know I would go in those
Gardens for four and five hours and take
little things I'd build little Villages
how was this imagination stimulated
because I wasn't comfortable around
people
so I think a lot of artists come in that
way they come in a little different and
they're not comfortable around people
and so they begin to use their
imagination to alleviate that discomfort
and then what if an artist becomes a hit
and now dance for us again
and now they have to be on in front of
other people
and wait a minute my comfort zone was
creating this thing over here and I'm
used to being alone and
what happens then
wow that's that's tough that becomes
very difficult I mean there are two ways
that that happens you know I I've worked
you know I work as a creative consultant
so I've worked for a bunch of movie
stars and many of them wanted to be a
movie star that that's what they wanted
to do and you know some of them I think
you know they came in to do that I mean
it just is so apparent and then when I
would get there the big secret would be
they're not trained they go on this
desire and this work ethic and this
goal and this intention to to it's not
to be the best it's to be the most
popular
um which often comes from you know uh
not enough
attention feeling so I'm going to get
this massive attention anyway the first
thing usually when I meet them because I
was raised with these painters and
dancers and actors and writers
extraordinaire at the dinner table I
don't really care who people are I don't
care if you have a big name which is
makes me popular among those people
because it's very rare
and then after she made some months it
makes me unpopular because they're used
to
a you know a certain thing that I'm not
interested in anyway the first thing
that happens is they kind of admit that
um
I'm not trained I don't know what I'm
doing
and I'm always impressed with them
telling me that you know being so honest
but my answer is of course you know what
you're doing look at your career look at
where you've brought yourself you did
this this is no accident and so my first
step is to draw up all the things
they're doing right so we go through all
their films and their process and and
then they can see oh every film I do
have a technique I do do these 10 20
things and then I go oh we go from what
you're doing right into what else is
there what other opportunities are there
and then I would go and do that work for
them because they're very busy you know
and a movie star is promoting their last
film working on the film they're going
to shoot next and bringing up the films
of the future trying to find those so
then I have a whole lot of time so I
would do that work then you have the
person that you're you mentioned which
is the person who is in it for the love
and they just love acting and suddenly
they are a hit overnight and that's very
scary and and very difficult and you
know movie stars love the attention they
they they're very comfortable in that
light uh but not everybody is and not
every actor is and we've you know
part of the problems that we have today
is that
you know people are so critical and
they're so
your audience is so expanded because of
social media so where you would do
theater and maybe some people would be
you know in the back you know in the
alley after you perform them it's you
can have your autograph and you go yeah
and that was really nice now you know
you have to have social media you have
to have Instagram you have to have I
don't know Tick Tock and my luck and
like
it's it's crazy to me but you have to
have those things and that brings more
more people this is really one of the
reasons I gave up acting is that I'm a
shy
by Nature you know I want to be in the
woods I don't want you know
all those people looking at me I mean
that was one reason and
and the other reasons I'm too Alpha
I'm too Alpha to take my hat in my hand
and you know I was a trained actor so I
would work really hard on an audition
Iowa bring the audition to the people of
my little hat in my hand I would say
most of the time it's no I don't know a
19 out of 20 or no
and you know I would have put that time
in and the hair and the makeup and the
Wardrobe and the driving and the thing
this was a six hours on this just to get
there four hours and rehearsals maybe
that's 10 hour 12 hours
and you and you're gonna no no I'm no
I'm not gonna put myself in that
position that's me
that's me I I just too Alpha I'd rather
run the show and be nice to people and
you know have it go the way that I want
it to go but not everybody's that Alpha
so you have to find your way and what's
intolerable to you and what's tolerable
to you and what you can invent for
yourself how do I make it go the way
that I want to go
but lastly those those actors who hid it
and then discover I'm not doing well
with all this attention you know that's
a difficult Road and they need support
they need to be heard we all need to be
heard really they need to be heard and
they need to spend real time
creating it the way they want it to go
okay now you're hit now you can have
anything you want in the world
career-wise what does that look like
let's just take some time and breathe
and say what does that look like you
know I introduce people to the concept
of theater because you know theater
actors can work women particularly you
know it expands their lifespan as an
artist to do theater and there's nothing
more fun than doing theater in New York
in in London so you know you kind of
open up the possibilities and uh
really are sensitive to to the
difficulty of that of getting Fame when
you didn't really want it
you know you didn't really ask for it
you were just in it for the work